the Joe Rogan experience I saw this play
one time was written by Steve Martin and
it was a fictitious meaning between
Picasso and Einstein in a bar in France
it was called Picasso with la piel Geel
and in it Picasso's painting and he's
talking and he says an artist must stay
well [ __ ] otherwise his eye goes from
the page to the windowsill down to the
street a cross over to the cafe where
the girl sitting with her skirt up and
and it's like you got that's what that
always stuck with me yeah this fan
artist doesn't stay well [ __ ] they're
always gonna do the two and it's
thinking about getting late
yeah men will understand that but men
will rarely say that in the presence of
women and so because of that women
either don't believe it or they dismiss
it or they think you're a pig for
expressing it right all those things but
men alone they'll go oh yeah that makes
sense
like if you say that you got to stay
well [ __ ] like oh yeah of course you
have to otherwise you get [ __ ]
distracted that is true women have no
idea I heard a thing on NPR one time
probably 15 years ago and they were
doing a story about this woman who
decided to transition to be a man and so
she documented it and did like an audio
thing and she talked about how when she
was into and started feeling her
testosterone and she would become
attracted to women and she goes it
didn't have to be a boob it could be an
elbow it could be her ankle it could be
whatever and I would and she goes I
finally understood 13 year old boys
pretty [ __ ] distracting isn't it now
and dad you got to keep your [ __ ]
together
well it's not just that it's a
biological imperative it's a reason why
people breed like that's built into the
DNA to make people attracted to females
so they can spread their DNA and that's
what it is it's that simple it's it's it
deny that is crazy but you've got men
denying it because they want women to
like them and then you got women
dismissing it because they think that
the men who express it in an honest way
are pigs and sexist and they exhibit
toxic masculinity which is that
a hilarious expression because you need
to thank toxic masculinity for all the
bridges all the [ __ ] all the Jets all
the Rockets all this toxic masculinity
if you break down all the things that
men have invented and all these toxic
men have prevented like you from being
murdered in war and protected the
country and all these all the different
things that you could attribute a toxic
masculinity most of it's positive okay
now I forgot what this guy had this
question is it sitting in my head since
you started talking about toxic smack
the Lindsay that I [ __ ] can't even
get the word [ __ ] sovereignty toxic
masculinity is a ridiculous thing to say
there's this terrible men there's
terrible human beings that happen to be
men there's also terrible human beings
that happen to be women there's not
toxic femininity they're just they just
have any women women who developed in a
terrible way
most likely with bad parents most likely
abuse physical and/or sexual and then
they become a monster at the end of all
this process this is the same with men
bad men are just bad human beings that
happen to be men and when you see
terrible things happen it's not because
of toxic masculinity it's because it's a
bad person I believe in the individual
there's individuals and some of them are
bad and some of them are good but you
want if you just want to generalize
against all men like you're you're on an
uphill road there's too many and
obviously not me I've never invented
anything but there's too many things
that men have done that are positive
there's way too many there's too many
things if you wanted to have like a
scoreboard and you wanted to compete men
versus women
why would what are you gonna say when
you look at all the different
accomplishments that men have made and
obviously it's not man it's not you I'm
not talking about us like we're on a
team but I'm saying like just this this
concept that men are bad and you hear
this a lot today especially white man I
don't wanna hear from white men
okay well that's crazy because there's a
lot of nice white men like this is dumb
they'll not of you yeah he's one of them
but just just this idea that you can
generalize about one entire group
whether it's by gender or whether it's
by race but by anything but you can do
that with white men you can't really do
that with brown women you can't say
here's a
problem with black women you know all
black women are this that people do
you're a racist piece of [ __ ] but did
you say here's the problem with white
men both are gross both statements so
generalizations are disgusting whether
they're a gender-based generalization or
a sex based general whatever it is so
they would say that that's okay to say
that about white men because of the
power dynamic yes and white men have
power so if we say that it doesn't is
not even racist right right that's what
that's I don't know I'm not a dumb
argument not a professor so I don't know
if that's true or not but you know what
the white power this is thing white men
have more power sure but they also have
more power than white men it's a tiny
percentage of white men white men who
have the power that we're talking about
when you're talking about CEOs and
you're talking about you know judges or
what yes yes white men are in those
positions of power but they're also in
those positions of power over most white
men like it's it's not it's it's a very
small amount of people that have an
extraordinary amount of influence yeah
they happen to be white men but when you
say white men suck look at this like no
that's that's the smallest percentage of
people who are these billionaires who
are these CEOs who are these judges who
are these people that are in positions
of power that happen to be white men so
have you ever now again I don't know I
heard a guy refer to himself like a
regular guy refer to himself as assist
me
how I'm gonna do that from now on have
that has anyone ever done that it kind
of blew me like I didn't even know what
it was when I first heard it yeah it's
nonsense
well you're male if you're a trans woman
and you you want to be referred to only
as a woman fine no problem with that but
I'm not gonna call myself a sis male
that's some new made-up [ __ ] it sounds
like you're calling yourself a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah like when I first heard that
I thought that's what a guy was doing
when I when I first heard it a guy said
I'm a syst male blah blah blah I'm like
you're a [ __ ] I didn't know what it
meant I read this tweet once by this
person who was saying basically to shame
people into using that Ram it down their
throats and eventually they'll accept it
and it'll become normal and that you
have because if they want to refer to us
as trans
we have to refer to them as says we have
to force them process yes yeah I even
know that's where it came it's to just
to make a clear distinction so instead
of making it look like a trans woman is
lesser you set you instead of that you
have cisgender and transgender so
they're there because you're you're
adding to that name that prefix yeah
because you're adding to both now yeah
now you've equalized the playing field
you level the playing field but the
problem with that is trans is extremely
rare it's the reason why you have that
prefix in the first place because it's
really really unusual to meet a trans
woman despite how the internet would
have you feel I was always I'm sure it's
a tough life to be a transgender yes I'm
like incredibly tough I was always a
little jealous why don't you become a
woman I was always like god it looks
like fun why don't you dress up like
Megan McCain and just start going on
rants on your show you'd be free you
would have such a [ __ ] free pass I
mean look Caitlyn Jenner kill the lady
nobody even talks to us has anything
just slammed her into traffic not paying
attention rear-ended her into oncoming
traffic she's dead now
and no one even brings it up everyone's
like she's so brave
do you think she's intact I heard she
cut it off oh my god it's a con I yeah I
don't but that was accident right it
wasn't like it was a careless accident
Oh
still she rear-ended somebody and
slammed her in the oncoming traffic okay
and whether or not she was on her phone
I don't know
[Applause]